So Halloween has come around again so we thought it was time explore the previously unknown interface between pumpkins and thermite
Thermite is a word that is used for a few reactions but the most famous one is the one that
we're using here, which is a reaction between iron oxide, basically rust,
and aluminium powder. Now when these two react together,  it's hugely exothermic.
They release an enormous amount of heat. So much so that those products which are
iron and aluminium oxide (so the two kind
of swap over). The iron is produced as molten iron.
So the reaction is about 2,000 degrees. Iron melts at about 1600 I think
So we see molten iron pouring out of
this pumpkin's face into his poor friend's head.
And we see all these sparks flying
everywhere, and each of those sparks
is a tiny piece of iron thrown out from the reaction because it's so energetic.
I can actually pick up some of the pieces now that they have cooled down.
There are loads of actual bits of iron coming out of this reaction. There's a nice little nugget there.
And then a second part just because
we have some lying around was that we
stuffed some guncotton into our little friend down here.
So we have a nice fireball as soon as the thermite starts to make its way down.
Now I'm setting the reaction off with a piece of magnesium ribbon
because althought the thermite reaction generates lots of heat,
it also needs a very high temperature to get it going and magnesium ribbon is an easy way of
producing enough heat to just get that reaction to start
So, thanks for watching! If you like
what you saw here, don't forget to
subscribe and happy Halloween.